oh I have a question ready yeah yeah
what are you doing stand up okay when
are you coming on the road with me to do
Sam hey guys do you want to see will
sasso come out on the road with me and
do stand up cuz I do I bet you everybody
does it would be fun
I've never done stand-up in a serious
way because I'm not a stand-up comedian
well your honor we've talked not and
we've talked about this and the respect
I have for the game and there's people
off with your respect for the game I
don't people come up through the
trenches people like people like you in
New York I don't give a [ __ ] people like
our good pal Chris D'Elia
remember over a decade ago Chris did 500
shows in one year yeah but that's what
he likes to do is wake up and let's not
paint him as a hero he woke up in the
morning in a turkey sandwich and then he
did a show at The Comedy Store to show
that the laugh at his job yeah and then
he'd go in here he's amazing at doing
nothing yeah he's amazing at doing only
one thing like he can he can he's the
most uncomplicated human being in the
world there's a beauty in that and no
sex in comedy coffee sex in common
that's what she's called what's what he
should call his next step yeah he's not
interested in anything other than making
being a silly goose and and that's
[ __ ] there's room for him there's
room for him in the world he's not even
into food yet he's into food he's not
really into food not anymore because
he's like working out and he gets crazy
about that but he has a piece of weird
he doesn't need good gourmet food he
it's like shitty you know diner food
yeah he eats turkey burgers yeah he's a
turkey burger eating [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah but guys like that and I'm
talking about people that we know Bobby
Lee
who speaking of having a and you know a
an elusive age Bobby Lee 63 years old
that's a rumor he's he's been doing
stand-up for like 49 50 years I am yeah
and these are people these are good
friends of mine who are the funniest
people in the world who I respect yeah
and they do stand-up now I I dabbled in
some weird live comedy [ __ ] early in my
career then you know then I was on MADtv
early in my career yeah
I showed up on that speaking of an
elusive age I showed up on that show
when I was 9 years old 19 no you got to
be more I'm not
taran killam was 19 when I did magic
number 20 you're 20 I was 22 years old
so look at that bedroom Mike McDonald
looking at Bobby Lee as the funniest
[ __ ] incredible
he's incredible Jesus so Brian and I
were talking about Brian was being very
generous he said once you come out on
the road with me and want you open with
me once you try some [ __ ] out yeah
now I was just on one of your cohorts
he's over here right Theo von yeah where
is he next door yeah but don't don't
knock on that just keep talking about
well he's banging on the [ __ ] [ __ ]
when he's I know but alright anyway just
stick to alright so Saeng so feet and he
was like oh you know once you try
stand-up bro you could be like you could
be out there with a bag of potatoes just
being gang gang and it's like the I'm
working really good yeah you'd be out
there with a pack of potatoes and a and
a can of can of Cool Whip
yeah that's good so yeah so and we were
talking about it and I thought cuz I
used to do a character that did stand-up
we started it on the 10 minute podcast
David Greco yeah and then I would go out
and do this character but it's too
charactery right like it's all right why
don't you just you've got a voice will
sasso that's a good idea
yeah but what if I did this little sass
up but what if I did this yeah
what if I did stand-up as Will Sasso
yeah but I call myself something else
great
awesome just come out and do stand-up as
Will Sasso being somebody else and I
call it the guy maybe he's something
like Jeff ladies and gentlemen please
welcome Jeff okay great so Jeff and then
I just look exactly like me huh
maybe maybe I'll just wear some hip
glasses okay I used to wear glasses but
now I got LASIK so you don't wear
glasses but you have you have imaginary
LASIK
yeah where's some like fake glasses got
you like Randy Jackson would wear on oh
no
okay so you need well you need is to
hide behind something initially American
Idol as a man in a matters why I don't
matter in a mask and do stand-up yeah
look at Halloween masks just come on
do here's why here's one of the reasons
I don't do stand-up I don't give a [ __ ]
to share my opinion with a lot of people
and I feel like stand-ups are true
stand-ups like yourself are born you
have a lot to say you have a lot of
opinions you know I don't excuses for
not making it you so you could be one of
the great standards right that's that's
very wrong
oh you could well see pair of pair of
those pair of those like come out come
out I tell you what feature for me
horn-rimmed a lion mask what ya be why
don't ya why don't I just be your Bryan
Callen swarm up I'll beat you gone to a
Bryan Callen yeah you're G Kanto by now
giganto Bryan Callen yeah and I come out
and rise your your nickname yeah and
I'll get a silicon mask made yeah and
it'll look like you people get freaked
out and I would pay I would pay $10,000
for I'll come out in a skin-tight
cashmere sweater
oh and skin tight jeans I don't work
that down Valentino dress just like you
and a pair of kids [ __ ] shoes I'm one
of those kids know they're [ __ ]
adidas a-hole cute what are you a size
five oh you son of a [ __ ] ten and a
half so and then I'll come out there's
no no well what I hear let's be let's be
real
yeah let's be real yeah okay and I'm and
I here's let's be real
I want busy you're busy you're busy in
Hollywood so it's no excuse you're out
there doing your thing yeah I just feel
like if you haven't done stand-up yeah
if you haven't done stand-up yeah and
then all of a sudden you run out there
and you start doing stand-up yeah it's
kind of like it's a cheat I don't like
the totally disagree no because look at
like guys like Michael Richards and then
and then he's up on stage saying the
n-word now I'm not saying that's a
eventualities of course I'm not saying
that's an eventualities and
traditionally done Stan you're a racist
son of a [ __ ] so I would there's a past
there's a huge probability that I'll be
saying the n-word Jesus at any point
when I become even
little floss why would you do and that's
a risk because being up on stage is no
joke nobody know and then I'm just
n-word and we're racist yeah that would
be terrible
yes and they'll be gone forever that's
right gone forever banished that's right
to the forest having homosexual sex in
coffin alright listen with John Kerry
Jesus turned that and it's true I know
this so much yeah sorry
stop trying to he's like hijacking Asia
right now so here's my thing it's like
who's primarily an actor I make [ __ ]
that goes nowhere and whatever and then
you're up there telling Zoey anyway and
telling jokes it's like stand-up is such
a specific thing and like I'm saying you
know he's doing right now no I'm not
he's making whatever pieces for why he's
not gonna do stand-up like it's I'm so
bored with his long explanation you dog
here's the thing I don't want your
audience going cuz it is boring it's
like no guy's gonna be funny I know you
know how to do that I would like to hear
I'll come out with you we talked about
this and talked about this so I'm not
trying to like you know I'm not trying
to get on the air and do a bit I'm not
trying to like avoid what you talking
about right now
yeah have a different conversation than
what we had before right before the new
year
Brian was like once you come out do some
stand-up with me I was like that's very
generous of you Brian cuz you know Brian
packs the house and I'm a guy and you're
good so and that would be fun I just I
just I'm a weirdo and I feel like
creatively I would like there to be
something it's not it's not it's not
something to hide behind it's something
to make it interesting for me so that I
could show same thing happen on field
show he's like well what would you do
Gang Gang and I was like here's what I
would do and it was like so [ __ ]
boring to talk about it you got to do it
well Alex you can't just stand up comedy
I want to do stand-up comedy all the
Jews
Joe Rogan said that I could come out to
his concentration camp he didn't say in
Valencia understand all the people out
there and he's harvesting up their
organs no he doesn't and Google is evil
no that's not true
and they yep and sundar pichai is is is
is is is is is is is let's go some
current events all right you tell you
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue
oh good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]